hey guys Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update facebook owner Mark
Zuckerberg just announced that they are
going to be purchasing oculus the
company behind the VR headset the oculus
rift for 2 billion dollars Zuckerberg
announced the news today on you guessed
it Facebook the deal includes four
hundred million dollars in cash and
twenty 3.1 million Facebook shares
valued at one point six billion dollars
the deal also includes performance-based
payout options that could boost the sale
by an additional 300 million in cash and
stock if certain milestones are reached
Zuckerberg said mobile is the platform
of today and now we're also getting
ready for the platform's of tomorrow
oculus has the chance to create the most
social platform ever and change the way
we work play and communicate oculus VR
is released a statement of their own
Mark and his team share our vision for
virtual reality's potential to transform
the way we learn share play and
communicate Facebook is a company that
believes that anything is possible with
the right group of people and we
couldn't agree more so what do you guys
have to say about all this do you think
that Facebook funds are going to help
oculus realize the future for virtual
reality or will Facebook's involvement
derail hopes for VR let us know in the
comments below thanks for watching